c'est le mot le plus recherché sur
internet en 2020 mais aussi largement
traités dans les médias le coronavirus
est au coeur de nos échanges depuis plus
d'un an et demi pourtant aujourd'hui
l'épidémie semble suscité bien moins
d'intérêt que les mois précédents et
pour cause la chute des contaminations
la baisse de la pression spectale hier
et l'augmentation de la vaccination
montrent que le virus est sous contrôle
en france à l'occasion d'un déplacement
en eure-et-loir emmanuel macron a même
laissé entendre un possible allègement
du pass à me taire dans les prochaines
semaines de son côté le conseil
scientifique alerte et craint un rebond
de l'épidémie recule de l'épidémie où
communication politique où en est
vraiment l'épidémie de kobe de 19 en
france
un constat positif
la nette amélioration de la situation
sanitaire se poursuit semaine après
semaine les chiffres publiés par l'
agence régionale de santé montre une
décrue de l'épidémie de kobe 19 en une
semaine les entrées en réanimation ont
baissé de 32%
les hospitalisations de 28 % le taux
d'incidence de 27% et les décès de 18%
cependant avec l'arrivée du froid le
professeur arnaud fontanet n'écarte pas
une reprise de l'épidémie
malheureusement j'aurais voulez vous
dire que l'épidémie est terminée l'arno
c'est impossible de dire ça et ça serait
malhonnête sachant que justement elle
est dernière à cette même période on
sait que quelques semaines plus tard et
début du mois d'octobre les
contaminations reprises le coronavirus
est une maladie qui sévit principalement
les atmosphères fermés dans les endroits
clos est confiné que par définition à
l'automne eh bien on va se retrouver
plus souvent en intérieur qu'en
extérieur parce qu'il va faire plus
froid tout ceci avec l'aération des
pièces moindre aéré souvent parce qu'on
a fermé les fêtes mois se retrouver dans
des conditions idéales pour des maladies
autonomie journal au moment du tournage
de cette vidéo plus de 70% de la
population française est entièrement
vacciner si les injections progresse une
flambée des contaminations n'est
toutefois pas écartée
thaksin et remis il est important
également plus d'un français sur trois
n'est pas vacciné y compris en comptant
dans ce dominateurs les enfants créent
clairement un risque qu'il peut y avoir
et contrer moment donné on aura atteint
un certain nombre de gens vaccinés et
peut-être toucher du doigt sa timide et
collective on ne sait pas si elle est
atteignable ça reste une possibilité
bien sûr si on n'arrive pas à faire des
rappels suffisamment rapprochée dans le
temps en fonction de la nécessité
d'avoir un taux d'anticorps élevée due
aux différents variant et bien oui à un
risque de voir des nouvelles bouffe et
sporadique dépit des mines le virus va
dépendre du nombre d'hôtes sensibles à
l'infection savoir que malheureusement
avec les variantes d'al talh des mecs
qui peuvent être porteurs même s'il
transmet des mois où peuvent transmettre
la possibilité d'avoir une population
qui ne soit pas si mais logiquement à
sensibles à l'infection virale fait que
effectué au cours de démarrage de
l'épidémie en termes de nouveaux cas la
raison pour laquelle les experts
s'attendent à une reprise de l'épidémie
c'est tout simplement parce qu'une
accalmie similaire a été observée
l'année dernière à la même période
suivie d'une hausse des contaminations à
l'auteur les virus respiratoires en
général pas seulement des arts skov de
ou une incidence centrée sur les sur les
périodes froides et humides et froids en
général on l'a vu l'année dernière à
l'automne dernier dans le creux des sens
qui était concomitante d'une dégradation
de
la météo et dernière à cette période
n'avions pas de vaccin nous n'étions pas
dans les mêmes conditions ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'à la fin du mois de septembre
l'an dernier et très peu de
contamination et souvenez vous il y
avait pas eu cette vague estivale on
voit bien qu'avec les variants n'était
pas du tout dans la même configuration
il n'avait pas non plus également
l'accès le même accès au dépistage si
les experts s'accordent à dire que toute
épidémie a une fin et la ii vient de
souligner que la fin d'une épidémie ne
signifie pas forcément que le virus ne
circule plus cette épidémie peut être
réduite à un stade endémique avec un
virus qui continuent de circuler mais de
façon moins graves les épidémies ont un
endroit donné un début un milieu et une
fin ce sont des épidémies qu'on regarde
un endroit particulier si vous prenez
par exemple la grippe qu'on connaît
depuis plus longtemps en gros les
limites de grippe ça durant six semaines
sur
un territoire comme la moitié de la
france est un pays si on prend toute la
france un peu plus long sur l'europe
c'est un peu plus loin maintenant son
regard à l'échelle de la planète fait de
virus circule tout le temps et quand une
épidémie s'arrête là mr note d'autre on
recommence dans l'hémisphère sud en ce
sens l'annnonce de la fin de l'épidémie
de covile 19 peut sembler davantage
politique que sanitaire on croyait que
l'une des préoccupations fondamentales
de l'exécutif c'est d'essayer dans un
contexte très incertain de gérer au plus
près une sortie de crise sanitaire dont
évidemment la signification sera
interprété politiquement déductif et
gris d'un côté entre sa volonté de ne
pas relâcher les mesures sanitaires
dans le même temps de continuer à faire
fonctionner la société on regarde un
agenda politique qui va être
profondément marqué par l'enjeu de
l'élection
présidentielle si le pire de l'épidémie
semble derrière nous l'hexagone et plus
largement l'europe ne sont pas à l'abri
d'une nouvelle vague poussé par la
baisse des températures
[Musique]